hillary i'll start with you what was it
like to take on this beloved series and
give it that female perspective twist
well okay
uh isaac and elizabeth could sell me
anything so
i think that i had a lot of confidence
with them knowing that they felt i was
right for this part and that i could
tell this story
um and that really it is its own
standalone show we're obviously
borrowing from a format and some other
important key things that made how i met
your mother works so well but you know
our cast is very different
no one you know my character's not you
know ted
reincarnated into a woman like it's all
very very different
this is the story
of how i met your father
it was hard to live in the moment in
2022.
i think that gave us a little bit of
comfort and just that the scripts were
really good like when you read a good
sitcom script and it doesn't need much
work and i was reading a script that was
written like five years before so like
some of the jokes were a little old and
they're like everything's being punched
up and updated and blah blah but like i
just got it instantly and so there was
confidence in the writing and you know
that carter and craig were coming on
board also was another thing where i'm
like okay i think no one's gonna do this
if it's not gonna work you know and and
so i'm i'm just i know there's die hard
fans out there my husband is a die hard
how i met your mother fan him and his
brother that was like their show and he
is like begging every day like is there
another episode you got emailed in your
inbox come on he's like seen up to seven
like so he's your litmus test so what
was his reaction well he might die if he
doesn't like what i do so i think he's a
little biased but he he honestly
genuinely like loves it and it's like
laughing out loud and i'm like watching
him like
okay i mean
there's dating jokes there's dirty jokes
what do you two have to add what's so
great about this show and were you fans
of the original i know this might sound
crazy but i've been on 87 tinder dates
this year my last date was the worst one
yet i was on another day before this and
i just had sex he told you that why
would he tell you that that's not even
the worst part well what i think so fun
to me is
on this set and it's such a rare it was
just so fascinating so half the crew on
our show
are veteran multi-cam just like pros and
most of them worked on how i met your
mother and then the entire
costume department hair and makeup
department every single actor and all
but one writer had never worked on a
multicam before so all of us were just
walking around doe-eyed sort of being
like is this how we do it by the way you
guys are on the
same set um elizabeth and isaac told me
you're on the marshall's apartment set
they brought it over and updated it how
did that feel
so i was trying to think of how to best
express how sexy you are to me
a song a poem and then it hit me
a board game
you just get women i think we thought
since like none of us really and none of
us in this room right now like
watched every single episode of the
first show or like you know not like
chris didn't watch until he got the job
but like i think the fact that they were
like don't photograph and post this set
we were all like
this is important you know
carter brought the swords from his house
and like yeah carter had the swords and
brought them like loaned them back to
set yeah
oh my gosh it was fun when when serge
and i walked through because they're
like this is your place all surging i
did was look around and be like all
right well
you brought the swords or like i'm not
responsible for this weird dog poster
over here that's clearly your
character's thing we were all trying to
figure out and everyone was like how do
we have this much space in new york
hillary i got to go back to you for the
kim catrell playing the later version of
sophie what was it like when you got
that news i mean she's an icon how did
it feel for you it felt overwhelming
where i was like am i worthy i don't
know
um
like the name the name came out and i
was like oh
i totally
can see that and
when she said yes i mean it was just a
big day like that was a big question
mark like who's gonna play it we had a
little bit of time
and when we heard that it was go i think
all of us like had a a little happy
dance that we just had to do because
it's such a great name to add to the
show
um it's a different character for her
chris said this earlier and i was like
oh yeah i really didn't even think about
that is that she is when you think of
her you think of new york city
and that's adding like a lot of value to
the show and she's just
so elegant and
like soothing and calm like when she
talks you're like oh my god sophie
figured her life out she she got it
together
and she's like you have hope yes you do
and she's but she's also cool and funny
and her timing was like perfect she shot
10 episodes in one day
and yeah because it's a flash forward of
her like sitting in her home telling her
son this story and that's another thing
that just like tugs on my heartstrings
that the banter that her and her son
have because i obviously have a son and
i can't wait to like maybe drink a
little bit too much wine and have him be
like you're annoying me right now get to
the chase
you know like that's it's really sweet
did this joke start to make you think
about how you might tell your own
stories to your kids one day 100 and i'm
already there a little bit like he's
nine and so he's starting to like hear
more and more
and
but you know it's going to be different
when he's 23 or however old we're
presuming my son is
um in this show it's just
i just closed my eyes and i'm like i'm
going to be there and this makes me
smile you know oh i love it yeah well
this show has some again some dirty
jokes in the best way how old will the
kids be i think chris you might have
kids too how old will the kids be when
they're allowed to watch how i met your
father oh i don't know storage is seen
with the vibe with the with the
the thing yeah sex toy and who get like
i'm the wrong person to ask because like
growing up with my parents my mom would
be like showing me you know sound of
music and
mary poppins and my father would be
showing me like good fellas
alien
um
so i i don't know that i'm the right
person to ask i mean you know they watch
it whenever they watch it i don't know i
i think the show is not so
no it's not sex in the city
yeah yeah it's not it's it's not just a
show that i had you know as a kid oh you
did exactly exactly oh yeah
so were you excited to hear kim was part
of this show i'm yes
i said earlier too that like it's
perfect that kim is part of the show
because you needed an icon for an icon
uh hillary to kim truly and
we
hillary frantia and i had had the day
off but we all
came in that day to just
bask in the glow that is
kim catrell and
she was just exactly how you would
imagine just incredible hilarious sweet
and and we just fangirled in the back so
no i was
so excited because i love that show i
mean it's such an iconic show your
career is being my assistant you're so
deluded
i mean you wouldn't even know what's hot
if it wasn't for me
nina unfortunately you don't seem to
grasp the vast difference between us oh
yes i do
you stood in line at studio 54.
i stood in line at studio 54
the movie and like you said her comedic
timing i mean we saw it with samantha
and we see it here too but she's so
different in this show she's really
different yeah yeah you're real right
like she's in a turtleneck you know
she's a little buttoned up i like that
yeah but she's like warm and open and
clever and like it it meant not that
she's well i wouldn't say samantha's
worm
okay
you know and so it's really cool to see
her
stepping into a different thing yeah
um
elizabeth and isaac both said they have
dreams of the original cast being built
into the world that pam fryman has you
know all of them on speed dial so who
would be your dream og cast member
appearance or cameo for me it would be
neil
do you like magic
um i guess
oh my god
do you have you would say the same chris
yeah yeah yeah probably kobe
she's just
i've met her a couple times she's cool
as hell i'd love to work with her it'd
be awesome if she showed up on our show
sounds like you you all have some ideas
that you'll be pitching as well
um i gotta wrap with you guys but do you
know who the father is have you been
clued in on the plans
it's chris
it's me
hillary keeps saying it's me and i'm
gonna go with that because for me that's
like job security so for now we'll say
it's me but i honestly have no idea i
really like tien's new answers i mean i
know we do know we do know you know it's
a man
it's a man he has hair
eyes
face
styles in his body don't tell too much
now okay okay too many